welcome back to Hannity Dallas Cowboys
owner Jerry Jones he's sounding the
alarm about the impact player protests
are having on the NFL he said quote
there's no question the league is
suffering negative effects from these
protests Larry Jones's is right take a
look this is only two stadiums as
weekend we could only run to one from
Miami and I think the other ones from
Cleveland look at all the empty seats
post kickoff look at this
it's empty here's what it looked like in
Cleveland Ohio for the Browns yesterday
we continue now former Speaker of the
House Newt Gingrich they want to keep
doing this if Roger Goodell - doesn't
take a stand this is the result I more I
have not I'm not watching NFL games I'm
watching college football now and I
think most Americans are waiting for the
NFL to stand up for those that fought
bled and died under that flag it's that
simple
look I think you're exactly right I
think what the multi-millionaire players
who are out there posturing don't
understand is most of us watch the game
to watch football we don't watch it to
watch political protests we don't watch
it to watch their personal
idiosyncrasies and frankly they ain't
that big a deal in the long run I think
that this has been devastatingly
negative for the NFL I think that the
absence of leadership at the level of
Goodell is astonishing I think that the
owners are about to decide that their
pocketbook is being hurt and I think
when enough of them decide that they're
going to talk to get out but it's really
sad I mean why should it be so just take
the last few weeks for young Americans
died in this year hunting down and
killing Islamist terrorists why should
it be so hard to recognize and
acknowledge their sacrifice by standing
up during the national anthem I mean
what is the sickness which is permeating
our culture which leads people to
believe that they have the right to
disrespect their flag their pledge their
anthem the veterans the people who keep
them free the people who keep them safe
and there's something sick about what's
happening in part of our culture and we
need to have the guts to confront it
head-on I want to ask you I want to play
for you Maxine Waters
and when I play this comment I want to I
want you to think about it through the
prism why are you looking at me why are
you glad you're not allowed to laugh at
my question I've known you for 20 30
years I want to play it mocking you I'm
thinking about Maxine Waters by the way
we're gaining my time or whatever she
said if it just went on I'm reclaiming
my time
alright but this is her saying she's
going to take out the president think of
it if somebody said this about President
Obama I am sitting here listening
watching absorbing thinking about Ali
even though I never met him and with
this kind of inspiration I will go and
take Trump out two nights
what's your reaction well first of all
I'm guessing that her reference to
Muhammad Ali is a reference to boxing
and so she meant it in the sense of
hitting you know hitting a ring first of
all you say you'd never get it to happen
but the idea of a round between her and
Donald Trump was pretty interesting I
think he'd probably win in the opening
half minute but I mean if he was
confronted if he was confronted with her
it would be very pleasant until she hit
him and the second she hit him he'd
knock her down let's be honest here this
is crazy Newt Gingrich's encourages
Trump to hit congresswoman I can see the
headlines now that's not what you'd say
yeah look my points this the the left I
mean I did this interview with a
reporter the other day and I cut him off
and I said you know you have a pathology
because you're pathological it was
totally stunned he said what do you mean
I said you are so anti Trump there's no
point in touch with the real world so
how can I have an interview I think that
thing Maxine Waters in the same group
there's this whole group of people or so
frankly crazy
all right let's circle probably out of
touch with reality now your confidence
that the Senate now will get this tax
reform bill done because if they don't
they won't better tell you yes I'm
waiting with bated breath for our good
friend Mark meadows and the freedom
caucus and others to come together as he
has indicated they will if the House
passes this budget this week and Trump
president Trump had exactly right if
they pass this budget this week and we
can move on to first of all the Ways and
Means Committee marking up a bill
sending it to the Senate which I think
they will do I think we got a real shot
of doing this as you know you and I have
been on this the whole time for
nine months this is a big deal it's you
I think I'm I'm a little bit a little
bit more optimistic tonight they better
get it done this is their job all right
mr. speaker thank you Congrats on the
success of the book